Joe Biden is going full speed ahead with his
cabinet.
Yesterday, we talked about three selections,
secretary of state, national security adviser
and ambassador to the United Nations.
Today, we have three more actually four more
to tell you about, which I will do momentarily.
And as great as it is to see Joe Biden do
this, it is also fascinating to watch the
car crash of Donald Trump just being so triggered
by Joe Biden moving ahead and selecting his
cabinet.
Yesterday, when I told you about three of
Joe Biden selections, I mentioned some tweets
that Donald Trump sent over the weekend about
how mad he is that Joe Biden is moving ahead.
As Joe Biden continues to make selections.
Donald Trump continues to tweet, despite Donald
Trump having effectively conceded the race
by telling the GSA to move forward with the
transition.
Donald Trump tweeting in certain swing states
there were more votes than people who voted
and in big numbers.
Now, since Rudy Giuliani has said, that's
actually a bit of an exaggeration.
Trump going on to say, does that not really
matter?
Stopping poll watchers, voting for unsuspecting
people, fake ballots and so much more such
egregious conduct, we will win.
And with every announcement from Joe Biden,
another tweet from Donald Trump claiming he
will win.
So we now have the privilege, and I really
consider it that.
That after four years of playing defense and
nonsense every day from this administration,
we are starting to get back into meaty and
substantive politics selections of people
who are actually qualified to be in the positions
for which they are being selected.
And let's review where we are so far with
Joe Biden's choices, of course, Vice President
Kamala Harris, that we knew she will be the
first female president or vice president.
And a very interesting selection, one that
in some ways progressives are fearful of.
In some ways, progressives are welcoming.
We know about Kamala Harris.
We knew about Donald Joe Biden, Rather's chief
of staff selection, Ronald Klain, who will
be a very boring chief of staff.
He will be scandal free.
And I expect him to last a while in significant
contrast to what we saw in the Trump administration.
Secretary of State Anthony Blinken, we spoke
about yesterday, National Security Adviser
Jake Sullivan, we spoke about yesterday and
ambassador to the United Nations Linda Thomas
Greenfield.
We also spoke about that yesterday, interestingly,
after Donald Trump sort of demoted ambassador
to the U.N. and pushed it out of the National
Security Council.
Joe Biden will be really evading ambassador
to the U.N. to a cabinet level role.
It will be part of the National Security Council.
I think that's important.
It shows that you are taking seriously the
relationship to the United Nations.
OK, we knew all of that yesterday.
New selection from Joe Biden as the cabinet
is filled out, Treasury secretary will be
Janet Yellen.
Now, Janet Yellen was previously the chair
of the Federal Reserve and she will also be
the first ever woman running the Department
of the Treasury.
Now, you know that I am not an identity politics
guy.
I want someone who is qualified.
And there is no way to argue that Janet Yellen
is unqualified and it is powerful and inspiring
and interesting that she will also be the
first woman in that position.
She is going to get a fragile economy in the
midst of coronavirus with high unemployment.
Almost certainly Yellen will be at the center
of a second coronavirus relief bill, which
we have every belief that Joe Biden as president
is going to try to put in place.
She will have a massive undertaking that she
will be walking into on day one and likely
even before day one.
And she will be tested right away.
Now, in terms of Yellen for markets, markets
will likely do do well as a result of this
market's early today liking the selection.
Yellen is a known entity already.
And, of course, for those who are on the right
and we're worried about, oh, socialism, Biden,
the socialist, the communist, the selection
of Janet Yellen.
We'll talk about the progressive reaction.
But the selection of Janet Yellen, if you
are in any way connected to reality, should
confirm that there is no socialism or communism
going on here.
Meanwhile, there are lots of progressives
who are OK with Janet Yellen.
She has gone after corporate power in the
past.
She went after Wells Fargo during the fiasco
years.
She's not an ideologue.
And at least as far as Joe Biden is likely
to pursue the economic agenda he ran on, Janet
Yellen is not the type of person who is likely
to get in the way of any of it.
It will still be up to Biden to actually pursue
it, to pursue it.
Some elements of it will be affected by whether
or not Democrats take the Senate.
There are many ifs, ands and butts.
But Janet Yellen is not someone who will get
in the way of any of what Joe Biden wants
to do that he ran on, much of which was at
least acceptable to progressives.
OK, we'll talk more about Janet Yellen in
the future.
Another very interesting selection, secretary
of Homeland Security will be Alejandro America's
first Latino in this position.
Also, a Jewish man who has taken very seriously
the issue of anti-Semitism will be very interesting
to see him take that head on as secretary
of homeland security.
What the policy questions will be right away
include what does he do about family separation
and the caging of children, not trivial things
that will be sorted out by the individual
in this position.
A very interesting choice.
Director of National Intelligence will be
Avril or Avril Haines will be the first woman
in history in that position.
How does she clean up this fiasco of lack
of trust in the intelligence can?
Unity as a result of four years of Donald
Trump slamming them, she has her work cut
out climate czar.
This is a very interesting position.
John Kerry will be climate czar.
Now, merely having a climate and environmental
czar is a move in the right direction.
Kerry is super smart.
One of the people I met earlier on in hosting
the show, this position will be on the National
Security Council.
That's important, recognizing that climate
is a national security issue.
This is a really great thing.
Now, one other thought.
There are really interesting identity stories
here, but absent the identity stories, there
are all qualified people in these positions.
And even folks on the right who are not lunatics
are saying we find that a lot of these choices
are too far left, but every single one of
them is qualified.
Now, in addition to that, there are interesting
racial and gender stories to be told here.
And I don't think that it is playing identity
politics to recognize that we're going to
do deep dives into the politics of this cabinet
once it's fully selected.
Remember that these positions are set for
Senate approval.
They depend on Senate approval.
If Republicans end up controlling the Senate,
they are going to put up roadblocks for Joe
Biden for at least some of these positions.
It is conceivable that if Republicans really
want to obstruct, Joe Biden may have no choice
but to use interim or acting appointments
to get around Senate confirmation.
Remember that Republicans have been going
on and on about Obama sat on all of these
the or rather the Democratic Senate under
Obama for those couple of years blocked all
of these selections.
We are going to very quickly see whether Republicans
are going to do the exact same same thing.
The upside right now is that normal nonsecure,
non, non fascist, non ideological extremist
lunatic types are rapidly set to be in charge
of the country just eight and a half weeks
from now.
That's a really important thing.
Last thought on cabinet.
And then we're going to take a quick break.
Anti-Semitism is already going crazy because
of the selection's there are some Jewish folks
who are going to be part of Joe Biden's cabinet
and staff.
Ronald Klain, his chief of staff, is a Jewish
guy.
Kamala Harris husband is Jewish.
He will have no formal role.
But, you know, antisemite don't care about
that.
Janet Yellen is a Jewish woman.
Alejandro Mayorkas is a Jewish Cuban guy.
The usual suspects are already very upset
about the number of Jews here.
And we are already seeing that boil over in
some of the right wing enclaves of the Internet.
The groups that track anti-Semitism online
are already aware of it.
And that I mean, listen, we'll have time to
talk about that, but that is rearing its ugly
head once again.
Let's take a quick break.
Let me know your thoughts about some of these
choices.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
I got a bunch of emails, people saying, David,
you sound sick today.
No, I'm just at a different a different studio,
different location for the Thanksgiving week
using a different mic.
I sound a little different.
I'm not sick as of now.
Could wake up sick tomorrow, but I'm not sick.
We have not lost the studio.
We have not been kicked out.
The show is not circling the drain.
I am just elsewhere this week and we have
a very, very busy week of shows upcoming
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.